Michael Bloomberg has just pulled 13 and 14%
in two national polls and we've got to talk
about what is the path.
Michael Bloomberg, particularly if the DNC
dissatisfied with Joe Biden's disastrous performance
in Iowa, decides that maybe they want to change
establishment horses midstream.
So remember the DNC changed the rules a few
days ago to at least potentially allow Michael
Bloomberg into upcoming debates despite the
fact that he's not accepting individual donors,
which up until now had been a requirement
to make the debates.
He now needs 10% in approved polls and incredibly
13 and 14% in two polls.
Bloomberg is in third place, either by himself
or tied with Elizabeth Warren in two polls.
Now morning consult from a couple of days
ago has it as Biden 28 Bernie 24 Warren and
Bloomberg tied at 14 and Pete boot edge edge
back at six.
Then in the Harris poll, you have Biden 31
Bernie 20 and Bloomberg 13 one point ahead
of Elizabeth Warren.
Of course, statistically within the margin
of error, this needs to translate to votes,
right?
That's the thing.
So these numbers suggest to me that indeed
the DNC, the DNC is going to have to decide
in their effort to deny Bernie the candidacy
and enlight of Joe Biden's poor performance
in Iowa.
Do they want to get behind peed, booed, edge
edge?
Do they want to, it seems less likely, but
maybe get behind Amy Klobuchar the other kind
of establishment centrist or do they want
to start looking at Michael Bloomberg who
of course has effectively an unlimited amount
of money to spend a, has more than $55 billion,
personally has already poured between one
and 200 million into ads and potentially would
do a lot more if the DNC were to get behind
them, behind him.
But then what happens in individual States?
That's also a question because Bloomberg skipped
Iowa and New Hampshire, barely a blip in Nevada,
South Carolina, almost not there.
Bloomberg's focused on super Tuesday.
So you know, polling zero in Nevada, but no
polling since January.
Maybe he could end up doing better.
They're pulling zero in South Carolina, but
that poll is 10 days old in California and
Texas, he's actually doing something between
four and 7%.
The national support will mean nothing unless
he can start accumulating delegates.
I said before, I think he may do it starting
on super Tuesday.
Uh, but if he doesn't, then this will all
be essentially for nothing.
So where do you think Bloomberg's going?
Will
the DNC
get
behind him?